touchy mache middle-class famous tour
update kippy uh-oh we got a couple
alerts going out straighten them out a
little bit kansas city springfield st
louis nashville in the philadelphia that
show sold out already three months ahead
of time we added a second show tickets
are on sale right now then we're going
up to providence rhode island that's
gonna sell out in boston this is low
ticket alert so get those tickets now
we'd love to see you do it welcome to
another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is ru garbage uh-huh little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find that they grow up to be classy
after just a big old piece of trash
i'm your host dave trolley coming at you
on a beautiful day down here at antony's
basement stumbled a little bit
fake she's very upset at who at us oh
[ __ ] yeah take the trash out what do we
do not to trash call us
power bill saw that ac bill
freaking out up there she also told me
to tell you trogdor is all right
my carlos is coming at you from across
the table he is the ceo of ru garbage he
is an international businessman he is
not to be tripled with in the boardroom
the bedroom or the bathroom kate butz
huh give it up for kj kevin james ryan i
like that one that was good hey gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate review subscribe
uh on itunes full video available on
youtube as you know those numbers are
true
kicking oh boy closing in on a hundred
thousand over there which ain't too
shabby they send you a nice little
plaque too oh on youtube
really like one of those things schultzy
has yep sweet cool youtube guys logan
paul the other guy hanging out yeah
we're doing it uh and then obviously
head over to sweet sweet patreon.com
ru garbage you get bonus content you get
uh episodes of ayg every week you get
episodes of hard feelings every week for
the 10 homies and up
um we're gonna be doing a lot of behind
the scenes stuff stuff from the road a
lot of shenanigans in the hotel rooms
and the green rooms the whole thing uh
we're gonna do a lot of travel stuff so
check it the [ __ ] out gang yeah please
do and having a nice quick shout out to
our producer extraordinaire the magic
man makes us all look good crosses the
t's dots the eyes give it up for t-bone
mcmuffin
toby mcmullan everybody hey what's up
dudes hey t-bone i gotta tell you fully
i've really you didn't do it this week
but i i really come around on mr neptune
2005. yeah i love it
thank you
thank you
i know what i'm doing over here kinda
and um a lot of people were hitting me
up about trogdor trogdor was actually i
tried to look it up and understand
apparently was cool yeah it was an
interesting still a dork
huge door and that man ain't helping you
either yeah let the audience know you
have a man bunny yikes
it's raining
can drop the kids off at soccer what's
going on
um yeah it was a cartoon can't get you
an extra fat latte
that was all right
uh anyway back to trogdor
what was it exactly it was a cartoon was
an internet cartoon but it was real
weird it was a snake that was shaped
like an s that had a muscular arm that
is correct
he was a man he was a dragon man
it's a good fit
sure maybe over there on reddit or
something meanwhile in the real world i
was watching shark tank
and for that
learn how to put a business together for
that reason you're a dork
ah that's nice we're having fun down
here in a basement i wanted to keep that
where we are the basement we are down
here in aunt toddy's basement as
everybody knows uh wanted to ask you
this uh buddy i'm here for it get your
opinion on you uh-huh um
ubers
okay
what do you think
i'm typically an uber pool man do you
worry about what you say when you're in
the back of an uber uh the other oh it's
funny you bring that up because the
other night
i we got i was we were trashing somebody
you and i yeah i was on the phone
and i was with with you oh russian
people yeah yeah yeah and i was like oh
man i hope this guy's not a comedy fan
because he is i mean some deep tropolis
but uh typically no i have that i kind
of have that thing
where it's like
i have i think about this a lot where
i'm like oh he does he's not thinking
but then imagine if somebody was in the
back seat of your car how much you would
hear them you know what i mean i hear
people's full conversations that sit
next to me at restaurants it drives me
insane uh-huh when they talk really loud
and they're like looking to you know
have you [ __ ] hear it yeah yeah
[ __ ] lady i'm sure you're a paranoid
pete you got to be worried about what
that guy's thinking saying sometimes but
it was not so more so like that i'm not
giving out [ __ ] you know classified
secrets
but like just goofing around in the back
seat with like my girl or teasing and
this and that she gets a little like you
know like stop stop stop you know stuff
like that yeah i mean i mean yeah but
here's what i really wanted to ask you
obviously when you're alone
um uh-huh how do you feel about ripping
one back there farting you fart
really now it's i mean come on
this guy's gonna be in the car all
[ __ ] day and you're you know what if
it has the plastic thing that's a little
dick you're like you might as well be in
an aquarium if you ask me that's a
little different that's like your own
little sweet couple stingrays going by
um
that's a little you shouldn't be farting
in someone else's car yeah that's like
that's a little more intimate than a
taxi taxis are like utility it's like
you know you're farting in a taxi i'm
not going in a taxi and a fart in a taxi
might improve it i don't know if you've
been in the new york city taxi recently
what about you there truck door
can't do it can't do it i i got some
real heaters coming i got i can't i
can't i don't i don't want that guy to
be like roll down the window and it's
like that's [ __ ] embarrassing then i
just in my head the next [ __ ] 15
minutes
yeah me neither
if i do have to do it i might try to do
the the fake cough to clear it up [ __ ]
yourself
pull over
[Laughter]
speaking of that oh i had remember this
was a big big big thing back in the day
uh i don't know if you did it but i'm
assuming in philly especially back in
the day you'd get an attacks this is a
pre uber you get in a taxi drunk or
whatever and you'd ask is it cool if i
smoke in here oh yeah and they would let
you just [ __ ] and they sometimes they'd
have them with you it was like a party
dude yeah yeah i'll have one too you're
like all right turn that music man let's
get cooking roll the windows down
um friday night in new york city after a
couple of two treats
beers in the back one going up the east
side highway cranking one oh man feeling
like the joker when he's hanging out the
window oh dude put on a little
springsteen yeah that's all right
smoking with the with the taxi driver is
a lost art form that doesn't happen
anymore and i thought about that the
other day because i got in a newbie and
a guy was just in there ripping one like
moments before like dude it was like i
got into an ashtray it was a [ __ ] and
i was just like this guy was just
sitting in here crap and you yeah you're
worried about farting who gives a [ __ ]
that's different how is that different
one guy smoked it's not like you get in
every uber and they're smoking but i
wouldn't mind farting in that guy's uber
i guess because i'm like all right if
you're smoking but it's like i'm not
just getting shoot me sir if you're
smoking poor batteries okay if i [ __ ] my
pants back here that's like walking into
some guy's cubicle and just [ __ ]
letting one rip he's gotta sit in there
for the rest of the day and you've
tainted it with god knows what
please tell me the genesis of this
questioning is that you ripped a fart so
heinous that you are now banned for
moving i'm a lift man now
i did go to lyft i did use lyft this
week no i was thinking i was having a
quandary if you might
uh if that's the right word i was
battling with myself i had some
intestinal discomfort as one might say
and i was like can i just make this head
what am i
what am i worried about here the windows
are down we're driving we're on a
highway if it's you know it's also like
he's got a mask on
that's
he's driving like a lunatic your fart
would dissolve the mask the strings
would just disappear
that would fall off his face and he
would turn to a skeleton the car just
disappeared
we're just riding on the axles
uh yeah i mean if it's an emergency if
you're like yeah it's painful whatever
and you got 15 20 minutes so you get out
but if like you're getting down a couple
of minutes i can wait then do it also
standing i feel is the best way to fart
sitting farts aren't always they gotta
they gotta make the turn what t-bone
agrees that's the craziest thing i've
ever heard no by by no means is that the
craziest thing you've ever heard or
thought today my friend all right
that's nuts though
yeah you always have to when you're
sitting down you have to that's what you
do you lift your leg like a gentleman
yeah but i'm saying when you're standing
the the fart it's there it's cool you're
there's there's no like it's not making
the the left hand the left hand turn now
i would say like a right fielder's
stance is probably the best way to go
yeah not sitting either way they do good
out there in the outfield when they're
bending down try to let them go um
make it happen i got something so you
know i had a little bit of a flood over
there at the apart not a flood a little
bit of water damage in the ceiling yeah
from uh from a rainstorm sure so they're
coming in
they got to do the whole bing bang boom
type thing and they're gonna get back to
us it's coming up soon
but we have two closets
one is pretty good
uh organize the organizational wise you
know what i mean i wouldn't be
embarrassed if you opened it coming take
a look around it's all you know
everything's in in order for the most
part
the other one
it's a scene in there man well you got
to take all that stuff out of there
anyway if you think i'm gonna do work on
it no they do it this is the this is the
thing he goes we'll come in and we'll
clear everything out now my question is
no no what you know i would have there's
no way i would let somebody clean out my
closet
i want to know what's in there i mean i
know what's in there there's nothing of
value in there it just doesn't matter
you clean that out yourself you don't
have somebody come in and clean that
when the [ __ ] does that ever happen
that's that's somebody that's going to
fix something in your house
like you know like when you when you
when you paint you got to move
everything into the middle of the room
or they do that painters will do that
people that's what painters will come in
i mean they'll charge you extra for it
yeah i would move all that stuff out is
that what you're asking should i move
this stuff out thanks for having fun
with it
i'm just saying i don't like that some
guy rummaging around and all my stuff
what do you got in there there's that's
what i'm saying i don't know it's not
great there's nothing embarrassing in
there but it's just a lot of [ __ ]
you know stuff from the dog luggage like
you can't touch the back of the big
closet and you can't touch the back of
the wall
because it's so deep it's yeah there's
just [ __ ] in there
stuff that i'm like you know probably
could all get thrown out and there's but
the thing is there's nothing damaged i
think they're used to doing it because
there's stuff damaged where they're like
wool removed
the what like the stuff that's been
damaged i assume that's typical protocol
oh so this is like your super or some
bozo this is this is like a restoration
oh
yeah i'm not letting the super go
through my [ __ ] all right this is a
service was any of your stuff damaged i
mean of course it was no it wasn't no
no what about all the money you had in
there
all my bitcoin that i keep from the top
shelf yeah no there was no there was no
actual water dam it's just on the
ceiling i guess it seeped through all
right nothing got into the the closets
nice
now i understand otherwise i wouldn't i
wouldn't let somebody just take stuff
out of my sure but also i'm at this
thing now of like foley's yelling at
guys i'm gonna wear that shirt in a year
hey if i lose 87 pounds that might fit
again
i have to have toby stretch it out
before i put it on there that's marc
jacobs right there fellas don't touch my
dreams um my thing is like my poems
uh
i am embarrassed to the point where i
have to do at least
but it's also that's what i'm saying i
don't know when they're coming there's
no keyboards or anything like that in
there is there keyboards like casios
like from my back back from my band days
uh
no but it's just like there's
it's you know
it's not great
so i gotta go i gotta do a once over and
i guess i assume i'll let them do the
[ __ ] heavy lifting yeah do the
once-over you know how bad is it in
there
it's not good really yeah so some of the
stuff could have been damaged
but there's nothing of value in there
don't i have some stuff in that closet
no i think i do
are you hiding snacks in there and i'm
not around no i think i have an original
copy the declaration of independence
is that where my bill of rights went
you and nicholas cage breaking into my
apartment listen fellas i'm going to get
your supervisor on the phone here okay
that's an original war hole right there
listen you're not going to believe me
but i stole the decoration of
independence
this will sound crazy but
yeah all right good stuff gang this is a
family episode
when you sign up for the old patreon
here you get a question question read on
air live here
with kevin mr neptune 2005. hit me
it was an award is that real
by the way could be
you're assuming it's like a bodybuilding
award or something that's what i'm
taking from it uh i thought what was
your what was your your thing well it
wasn't wrapped in logic right now
in sense of any stretch of the
imagination
um i assume that every summer in every
beach town
they award a
a lady
the mermaid award
okay okay the mermaid parade and then
and then whoever the the hottest guy
hottest guy is mr neptune yeah he is
yeah
that's what i was doing you had anything
on that
what's up i mean i don't think it's not
a real thing it's not a real thing i
don't i mean i don't know they don't do
that in wildwood they don't have like a
pageant on the boardwalk or something
what are you talking about you won the
mermaid yeah jesus christ
what do i think about that that it's an
honor and a privilege to be in the room
with mr neptune 2005. there you go six
and seven runner up don't you forget it
disqualified nate
i was juicing
yeah gang uh
as the big man says it's a family
episode so when you join a patreon we
will read your question on air sure uh
this one's from scotty b
shout out to scottie bizzle is it
garbage for a guy to wear a tank top on
a plane
that's a no-go for me i feel like you're
you can't have exposed pits there has to
be a body of water around for you to
have exposed pits i feel sure and plus
when you're sitting on a plane if you're
what are you going to reach and then
your [ __ ] armpits are on some other
guy and if your arm is touching just
just sitting if your arm and his arm are
touching and you're touching bare skin
that's that's what i'm yeah that's no no
no no yeah that's cherish i don't i
think tank top's annie it's that's gotta
be like a vacation you're not a tank top
guy you don't have a tank top body oh i
don't know i don't have a sweater body
what are you talking about
[ __ ] burlap saps burlap sacks over
here are good for me some guys can pull
off a tank top
they generally tend to be in shape yeah
and they don't look scuzzy
i look horrible and i think yeah i tried
those uh i tried a set of joggers on the
other day
joggers yeah oh like my pants yeah like
they
they're big now with these companies
it's like the casual yeah slack slash
sweatpants which i don't want to take
credit for the trend but
i'm just saying they're when i put them
on they're way more sweatpants
lululemon could send me a couple of
dollars yeah sure um
it's a tough look me and me and those
things really they look it's
i feel like i'm going out to gym class
in elementary school are they are they
you got to get them a little smaller how
you rocking them they got to they got to
barely fit trust me i know i just looks
like i'm wearing sweatpants really yeah
i got them to fly in because as you know
i only fly in jeans hold on did they
have cargo pockets cargo pockets on the
side i'm not a fat teenager i have cargo
pockets you got to go cargo joggers
that's how you do it no that's old navy
good fellas no we're a good fella don't
shop at old navy i'm sorry target i also
don't shop there unless i'm in a pinch
for dog food
that's not my it's not my stop for
fashion all right
good brain
yeah no they just i they just don't
i i look bad in them
yeah it's not great but that's again
like tank there's certain things that i
just don't look good in sure that and
like
i i got a i got a bunch of weddings
coming up so it's like i'm like figuring
out never look good in a suit in my life
fat guys don't look good in suits i was
just talking to my wife about this you
look good the second you you're together
right the shirts on the pants on the
jackets on the belt the socks the shoes
the tie
that's like taking
a you know a popsicle out of the freezer
you
the fuse is lit
you're gonna look like a melted candle
in about 10 minutes yeah it doesn't work
like when you cut open an avocado ah the
clock's right it's just [ __ ]
i have like six weddings coming up in
the next like [ __ ] three months you
could not go uh you could go
no suit
and do something a little joggers
nice set of joggies on you
no it's still the summer a little bit
yeah you gotta go jack you gotta go jack
you could go soup pants and you could go
long you could go short sleeve button
down
yeah but again i don't look
the guy on the magazine can do that or
the sean jackson jersey
always
end no he was a fuzzy you're like an
offensive attacker i think he was alive
if that's a lineman's jersey if you're
not related to him
oh man that's a tough look what i like
the kicker
oh yeah you could do that another thing
that doesn't look good i think i'm doing
no tie
sure i'm doing no tie i'm doing shirt
yeah oh [ __ ] the tie what are you
working nasa get out of here
i just look like a bad accountant like
i'm fudging the numbers and it ain't a
good tie i would assume now i got good
ties yeah you got good ties i do what do
you got i got a bunch of good ties give
me a give me a designer tommy hilfiger
uh i don't think so i don't know i have
like a bunch okay yeah what kind of ties
are you rocking i got a couple of nice
ones why should i believe you if you
don't believe me this with this logic um
yeah make up whatever you want and i'll
agree with you no i have a couple of
nice ties that my girl got from her boss
okay that's
[Laughter]
maybe put two and two together on that
they're real nice oh my girl got it from
her boyfriend uh they're like gucci and
somebody else you don't have gucci ties
and if you do they're pre-owned they are
pre-owned all right well get the [ __ ]
out of here i can steal stuff too you
know
i can go to the laundromat and pick up
the wrong order all right get out of
here if you have sex with her when he
gets up to go to the bathroom to take
the condom off
hit the closet ah
god another thing turtlenecks
off the shelf no yeah i can't do it now
never look good in the turtleneck
well there's a fat kind of drawer like
it's fun yeah some fat guys can pull it
off you know who's in fact our buddy
reggie conquest bigger guy wears good
stuff looks good and stuff yeah of
course that me or you don't look good no
good fashions yeah yeah but it's even
that the fashion it's like the apple
he's got whatever the frame is he's got
it for a certain thing i just don't have
a frame for certain articles of clothing
bathing suits no speedos no
anything but jeans and sweatshirts for
the most part now
i look okay in a pair of lacrosse shorts
somebody was while i'm sorry lacroix and
a button and i like this this is this is
the best i look
now you can look better when you try
i am trying
to be comfortable
okay let's talk about adam and eve baby
the windows are fogging up in here
draw the shades yellow adam and eve
shows up yeah huh tell the mailman to
keep his mouth shut yeah gang do
yourself a favor get over there to adam
and eve i'm gonna tell you right now you
want to talk about turkey you ready
what's that 50
off
using that promo code garbage over there
uh-huh that's what i'm talking about
listen we like to spice it up a little
bit you like a couple of two tree toys
maybe a little bit of this a little bit
of that maybe a little something ain't
talking rc cars either baby no i'm
talking heavy bike vibrators
we're talking naughty stuff that'll make
your mama blush that's what i'm talking
about you know everybody's doing it but
then straight to confession
your head down no eye contact uh all
packaging the screen aunt tooty won't be
finding out about this one i tell you
that and she's been rooting through the
packaging she likes to yeah
not only you save money on gas movies
and date night out adam and eve will
continue to save money and deliver tons
of fun go to adamandeve.com select any
one item and use code garbage this is an
exclusive offer so be sure to support
the show and use the code garbage let
them know the boys sent you and you get
50 off and free shipping go to
adamandeve.com right now do it yeah okay
let's talk about helix
speaking of good night sleeps
do yourself a favor get over there to
helix take the quiz oh i'm sorry i was
drifting off in a dreamland on my helix
twilight mattress
now how did you get that you get onto a
uh a mattress store and talk to russ
i know my own coffee my uncle graduated
with a guy who works
at a [ __ ] website took the two-minute
sleep quiz they matched him up with the
twilight matches i loved it so much i
sprung for the king size whoa
that's what we're doing around here
that's what i'm talking treat yourself
baby you spend what like a [ __ ] half
of your life in bed for you probably 85
percent you got to make sure she's
comfortable take most my meals in there
uh guys if you sleep hot cold big small
whatever if you like it firmly like it's
soft a little smack on the ass whatever
it is they will take care of you because
they will
um
even got heavy sleep for the big man
that's what they do but it's it's guys
it's really easy if you're if you're if
you're sleeping on a mattress you got
from
you know your dead uncles aunts sisters
boyfriend or whatever what are you doing
you gotta go pick it up though right oh
dude no they ship it right to your
[ __ ] house
what are we doing uh helix is offering
up to 200 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com garbage one more time
baby helix sleep.com garbage with helix
better sleep starts right now do it the
camping video is up on uh that their
patreon uh 20 minutes shout out to
t-bone for [ __ ] cooking the attic and
new guy luke with uh some of the shots
as well
um somebody said because we were
swimming in the gopro in the lake
jumping around someone said i'm built
like a cello
no no no no i think i thought they said
cello the
the i thought i meant to i thought they
meant the chocolate
candy
isn't that rolo no no celo is a
how do you spell cello
is it c-e-l-l-o yeah oh okay maybe it is
i thought they meant that the the
chocolate-covered cherry candy called
cellos that dads always get they're
always right in the front those are
sellers sellers okay
maybe he had candy on their brain i
don't know
it's not a good look he's a classical
musical instrument ah nah he means candy
it is
it is very soft in appearance what your
body frame
sure it almost looks like you have no
bones
okay
and what would you look like then i'm
not listen i know but i'm just saying
i'm not saying it's great
it's far from
this is why this is why we are where we
are
i so it just because i'm disgusting i
can't comment on somebody else possibly
being disgusting you're built like a
king's hawaiian what do you want from me
i don't know you're soft you're doughy
what do you think you are
you look like a fat sack of fat over
there
now you just try to hurt me
yes i'm aware yeah i feel like i got a
little bit you know a little shoulder
definition arms this is why you're 400
pounds you go i think i got some
shoulder definite yeah a [ __ ] you're
built like a
something i can't think of it because
i'm so i'm so flustered at the moment
you got homemade buns on the brain
okay
let's pull the e-brake on you real quick
um
but yeah um i think i think for the i
think i'm going to try uh
uh what was the question that was the
tank top question but we got off on on
guys wearing clothes right my brother
always had the thing he could like go by
i mean come on he's a [ __ ]
good-looking kid he could just go buy a
suit like literally all threat go yeah
i'll wear this tomorrow and i'm like
what the [ __ ]
yeah sucks mine's got to get sent away
it's got to come back i used to have to
get my catholic school uniform altered
oh that was embarrassing for pockets for
snacks
hey hey can you sew a clark bar right in
do you mind doing that
no always had to get those things
[ __ ] jacked up
it was like taking a cop car to get a
[ __ ] put armor on it they'd put like
skin they'd put
knee things on the inside uh some tough
skins and they'd have to fold up the
thing and [ __ ] stop brutal
mr t in a welding mask
on your pants
maybe if i tack weld the suspenders on
this fat piece of [ __ ] won't split them
locked in a wood chin paint they didn't
dance and they'd play it real slow
doesn't it always come busted out
wow now just me walking
out ah yeah it's a tough look i ripped a
pair of joggers this weekend my blue
ones my baby blues
plus you got you got [ __ ] wine on the
other one then i still need a couple
more washes to get out i don't think
that was like six months ago that's not
coming out now i think it will a couple
more washes it'll come out sometimes it
just takes time it's like a breakup no i
don't yeah that's true but i'm down to
just my jeans
that's all i got is those black jeans
yeah why don't you buy new clothes i
don't understand this you make a good
living why do you only have two i'm in a
transitional period right now
you have money to buy it 30 dollar pants
to wear hey you got to go and shop and
order try it on what are you talking
about
i don't know i'll see if i can sew my
joggers back together
i pity the food away these joggers
um all right this one's from bryce long
time listener have you ever as a child
but it's someone else's house and hurt
their parents having sex oh i thought
you've been fighting i've heard my
[ __ ] friends parents fighting yikes
but it's not yours it's weird
yeah i kinda i feel comfortable with it
you do [ __ ] these people i don't care if
they get divorced you know what i mean
welcome to the party daddy
hey welcome to two christmases and
breakfast for dinner let's do it not the
perfect family now huh mikey huh
yeah no i don't i never minded that i
don't think i've ever heard anybody
boning either
no never i wouldn't mind it
no yeah there's a couple yeah there's a
couple uh sure a couple of couples i
wouldn't mind uh you know hey i'm with
you on that hit in the powder room you
know yeah
two three two three moms out there not
two sheepy yeah
yeah
but i never did
always kind of suspected at certain
times like i've been like yes
i never heard my parents bone in
um all right this one's from official
garbage inspector
my aunt bought a picture frame collage
and hung it up without taking the stock
photos of random families out that's
what i'm talking about that's all right
i used to love going into [ __ ]
marshalls or wherever she was getting
her frames from and walking around and
looking at all the people in the
pictures how great their lives were it
was before i realized that they were
actors yeah that they were i read them
as actors right away yeah whatever i
mean come on i i read them as actors
right away i knew that and i'm like
these [ __ ] weirdos are just like i'm
like there's no way this is a family so
that's a kid that's a lady that's a guy
they all got day jobs i'm like this is
[ __ ] weird that they're standing out
in the field acting like a family i
never got that ever
i'm too cynical or whatever i was always
jealous of their lives it looks like a
really nice wedding
no i i pictured their real life i'm like
that guy's in a studio apartment [ __ ]
eating you know macaroni and cheese for
dinner hamburger helper with no
hamburger
that's what that guy's doing
that's not paying the bills i don't
think so right maybe back you're not
getting residuals from that
no that's probably like a 1500
flat rate or something back then it's a
photo shoot no not 1500
a thousand now
less yeah whatever that's even worse
yeah okay so 500 bucks for the kid's
probably getting nothing
yeah
it probably goes into a trust the family
steals it that's what i would do of
course
but now you got your head shot and every
marshall's coast to coast it's true did
you have any child actors in your in
your school in my school yeah yeah you
were friends with there was a girl uh
not that i was friends with a girl
younger than me was in the departed
really yeah who was she in the departed
uh
the guy the guy uh
he asked if she has her period yet
that's the girl he ended up marrying you
know that right that's her all grown up
i think that's what we heard yeah yeah
100 yeah no [ __ ] uh-huh she was vin's
kid whatever she was
the worst the diner or whatever
yeah
yet uh-huh yeah
a couple of comic books couple loaves of
bread
it's pretty nice yeah i really only gave
him a couple coupled some change
yeah back in the day it's a lot of money
i guess you're right we're talking the
seven days here loaf of bread true
the inflation nowadays that's like 15
grand
um
i don't think i don't know we've seen
another kid too that seemed a little
small time for him back then he's
shaking down a [ __ ]
little corner store
i don't know all right
i mean why are we dissecting [ __ ] uh
a movie from 15 years scorsese's vision
yeah um
a filler scene at that
um we did have another kid who did a
couple of movies
i think he was in the sixth sense
a lot of kids in philly in that sixth
sense yeah something another one that
was shot in dc but that was it do you
have any do you have any fame not famous
but like anybody of any sort of
notoriety no but at the theater there
was a couple of young kids that took
classes there that were like you know i
was in college they were probably like
in seventh and eighth grade real pricks
because they scored a couple of [ __ ]
parts
so
[ __ ] them yeah that's that's the age
foley i know yeah 20 years old high on
coke mad at a seventh grader sounds
about right everything's checking out
down here
pushing backstage [ __ ]
[Laughter]
tell your mom to pick me up earlier too
you're like kramer on the way to [ __ ]
karate class
um
yeah that's all i remember i don't think
anybody else
there was always like oh my cousin or
somebody there was always like an uncle
or somebody that did something but never
anything of notoriety
nobody in like top gun my dad used to
rent a building off ron jaworski but
that was about oh really yeah that's
pretty sweet shout out to jaws shout out
to jaws yeah i met him a couple times
had a couple autographed pics he really
dabbled in real estate out there in
philly he probably cleaned up yeah ron
jaworski was a quarterback for the
philadelphia eagles in the 80s 70s yeah
probably late 70s early caught him jaws
jaws yeah got after it shout out to him
um
i meant yeah that was about it him and
mike piazza really cleaned up out there
yeah
do the car dealerships he owns them
piazza yeah piazzo honda oh yeah yeah
hondas that's what he's pushing i
remember not be i remember as a kid it's
not much of a dirtbag as a kid i'd be
like you can't buy that guy plays for
the mets the [ __ ] we doing buying a car
off what are we doing to make these
[ __ ] idiots richer
get lenny you get [ __ ] mike schmidt
to open up an acura a lot and i'll get a
car
what the [ __ ] am i putting money in a
mets guy's pocket put this queen's [ __ ]
out of business you kidding me kick
rocks take that [ __ ] back to shea
stadium or whatever right he was not
down here he was a nordstrom kid i don't
give a [ __ ] he's a met
get the [ __ ] out of here putting that
[ __ ] on route one get out of it you got
some [ __ ] balls on you piazza take
that [ __ ] up the floor yeah at least
jersey's neutral territory i'll give you
jersey
the [ __ ] addy i remember being i was
like seven
like what the the balls on this guy to
set up shop in my backyard
i even call me tell me he's operating
you know what i mean ask where he let me
know he's operating in my [ __ ] in my
neighborhood slash all the tires on a
lot pieces [ __ ]
care where you went to high school
you're taking money from new york
bastard i know get the [ __ ] i didn't
know that makes sense he's local now
nah he's not that big of a guy
that was literally the only reason i
didn't like i never i wasn't even a
baseball fan wait you didn't know that
he grew up in norristown why the [ __ ]
would i know that he was a met i'm not
learning the stats on this [ __ ] this
jail
it's good stuff
uh speaking of cars this is from user
account new homie here is it garbage to
drive a wrapped car to make extra cash
on the side
what does that pay
cause i've thought about that dude i
remember what if before i even got my
license on i'm doing that i don't know
you were i wanted to do it yeah make
make some [ __ ] scratch what are you
making because there's a dude rolling
around my neighborhood now with some
energy drink
uh it's not monster
it's something looks pretty whacked to
be honest with you
um but he's a grown man
and he's just driving around his car and
i thought he might have been like a
um
what do they call like a rep or
something yeah
but now could be an investor or
something
maybe uh it says with a legitimate car
wrap you can expect to earn roughly 100
to 450 bucks a month depending on how
much you drive and how big of an ad is
on your vehicle what the [ __ ] 450 a
month oh 450. yeah that's the car
payment right what i'm saying i get the
jeep wrapped up
that's not a bad idea yes yes it is
first of all it's a lease i think you
wrap a lease why you can't just take it
off before you turn it in i don't know
i'm sure there's something hmm would you
i'll drive the ayg car around town
yeah i'm not paying you 450 bucks a
month to do that 400. 375 210 210
pay my easy pass but it comes out of the
ayg as an operating expense okay
i don't even know what that is exactly
nice um
yeah no uh
i always wanted to do that that makes
sense i mean what the [ __ ] if you
i'm borderline like don't give a [ __ ]
i'd be like yeah i don't care about my i
don't care about cars or anything like
that so i'd be like yeah i'll [ __ ]
what would you have got what would you
yeah dude [ __ ] you know lee's hoagy's
check and please hoagie anything dude i
like elise anybody that was rapid i
would have you know shout out to lee's
tuna hoagie um fantastic
remember the napa auto part delivery
guys i always wanted to be one of them
too
i remember applying for that job in
college i wanted it so bad
you would like drive you would like
deliver car parts in a car like there
was no truck or anything you were just
not that weird that weird little van
yeah wow [ __ ] that little van dude
you're just driving that thing that was
like something dr seuss with the tunes
blasting cranking heaters all day get
out a bunch of mufflers back there yeah
a couple of [ __ ]
couple of turn signals in the back yeah
that'd be all right i would love a job
what's your dream job outside of this an
actor that's never gonna happen
that was hurtful
and unnecessary um
baseball player
outside i mean like you had to go and
you have to no this is this ceases to
exist you have to go enter the workforce
right now yeah like you could be you
don't have to learn the skills like just
imagine you're skilled i would jump
straight out that window
in the basement
i go upstairs and i jump straight up
that window if you got to enter the
workforce in something the workforce
yeah i don't understand what you're not
getting about this what is it what is it
[ __ ] wartime
i gotta go [ __ ] make bullets what are
you talking about
uh i would like to own my own hot dog
place hey okay why did you give me so
much [ __ ] pushback when you had the
answer because you made fun of my act
i was acting upset which i truly was i'm
a method actor
i think you're a bald piece of [ __ ]
who's shaped like a candle
whatever yeah hot dog foleys and for the
record i you know i think you're a great
actor hey thanks fingers are crossed
kip bespoke post yeah box of awesome
uh-huh summer time it ain't over yet you
still got a little life out there in the
summer dude enjoy the wonderful water in
the woods and you don't want to go out
there you pull out your pocket knife and
the blade falls off and you don't know
that a bear's ripping your throat out
you want a heavy bike material yes you
do do yourself get a box awesome they're
absolutely fantastic get outdoor stuff
you get grooming stuff you get grilling
stuff you get bar stuff i didn't even
tell you
four days ago they sent me another box
yeah yeah and it's got one of those uh
the for cocktails the smokers
really what they got the little mesquite
little thing goes you got cinnamon
cooking put the glass put the jar on top
of it smoke it out you get one of those
i'm hop boxing my whiskey's over here
then into a white claw not good
i was just more like you get one of
those swirly spoons let me know i like
those twizzler
they got everything they got cool guys
[ __ ] you don't know you need i might but
my wife had a couple of those in the
building came over and i broke that up
hey look at
that did you really smoke it i was
slipping out of his chair he was like
that guy was all hot dude fire alarm was
going off but what the hell i'm telling
you man it's like you it's he was like
where did you get that guy it's so big
there boxing awesome check it out
[Music]
uh guys the box of awesome you're
supporting small business 90 everything
comes in a box of awesomeness from a
small startup an up-and-coming brand you
get 20 here's the turk
20 off your first monthly box when you
sign up at box of awesome.com enter the
code garbage at checkout that's box of
dot awesome.com code garbage for 20 off
your first box box of awesome dot com
code garbage now back to the shop back
to the show uh yeah open small hot dog
joint be fun small hot dog joint you got
to get a hot area i want brick and
mortar okay
only do them a couple different ways i'm
not doing this hollywood [ __ ] no
offense no chica maybe a chicago dog to
be honest with you all right shout out
to the bear there's nothing wrong with
it that's what that's a pickle
green relish
ketchup mustard put it all on throw it
right in the trash onions nothing on it
uh no ketchup no kid like rule number
one all right chicago all right please
don't ruin this
sports peppers sports peppers yep that's
it nah i'm done somebody lost me no not
doing it
sports pepper celery salt
celery salt
all right poppy seed bun
okay now i'm not getting the poppy seed
buns chili dogs is where it's at that's
what the kids want these days
doing plain maybe a little kraut make my
own chili sauce my old man's got a
really good chili
chili dog recipe
that does involve celery salt to be
honest look at this full circle you lost
me with sports peppers what's a sports
pepper
so guys my pepper to play hockey you ate
a chicago dog and enjoyed it i'm not
saying i don't love it but i didn't know
i was eating something called sports
peppers that sounds made up there's hot
peppers there's sweet peppers there's
banana peppers there's roasted peppers i
never heard of sports peppers you just
you didn't even name peppers you named
genres of peppers that's true there's no
pepper called the sport pepper
there is is there yes where is it made
what
peppers yeah it's made at the vienna
factory and it's goddamn delicious
sport peppers
why are you looking at me i'm somebody
who's asking me to google it he's the
[ __ ] he's the google guy he's talking
to me i can't google and defend the i
never heard of sports deliciousness
just because you haven't heard of it
doesn't mean they don't exist you also
the dumbest guy i know
i mean that's got to count for something
here in flavor and appearance sport
peppers which are from the capsium enum
species are similar to the tabasco plant
just a little smaller in green or yellow
instead of bright red it's a it's close
to the pepperoncini a milder pepper that
tends to get pickled and used in the
same way shout out to the pepper cheese
there's a pepperoni [ __ ] potato chip
floating around out there yeah hachi
pacinis are all right
i apologize about the sport pepper
i'll consider the chicago dog
no no no redo the menu
for
you get so mad when you don't know what
something is i know 100 000 initial
investment for 10 of the company
no
oh for that reason i'm out i think i
would be some sort of uh
smaller uh bald man boat captain of some
sort
yeah
that would be great
where are you gonna go whatever the job
requires what kind of boat whatever like
a pirate
boat a tugboat why not
you're not tugboat material what are you
what are you talking about you don't
even know what hot [ __ ] sport peppers
are and you want to open a hot dog stand
what are you talking about
the tugboat is
is the repo man of the sea yeah i go
[ __ ] i'll go i'll go you know whoever's
behind our bills go flex on them a
little bit
go [ __ ] with carnival huh i'm taking a
boat right now uh uh
yeah no i just remember i was like we
were like super stressed fishermen i
wouldn't mind that i grew up on but i
grew up on boats i love [ __ ] but i
would you know i love boats they're
great out on the water
they leave everything lake or ocean
either i mean preferably ocean but you
leave everything on the [ __ ] lane
you're just like that's out there that's
[ __ ]
you [ __ ] wackos deal with that i'm
out here cruising
a lot of bernies i'd go back if you're
if you're on a boat
bernie's and coors lights but i just
don't see how you would make driving a
boat at the end of the day you know what
i mean i can't get too [ __ ] though
what would you actually do whatever see
you can't that's not specific i need a
specific job hot dog i gave you tugboat
captain tugboat captain yeah all right
you want to be a tugboat captain i can
get behind that whoo
do you have to join the coast guard to
do that no oh really what the coast the
coast guard's
one of the
armed services well who writes the
tugboats
you think tugboats come from the i
scored i thought
i thought tugboat was a government
don't
job
the people running the harbor out there
they're not all
i figured that'd be a city job you're
like a tow truck driver yeah oh yeah i'm
sure is there's third-party tugboats
yeah
tugboats are expensive yeah i'm not
buying it maybe i do maybe it's a lease
to own owner operator type thing okay
yeah
i wouldn't mind driving i like driving
but like i don't want one of those big
rigs give me something small [ __ ] that
give me like a sprinter van or something
making deliveries what am i making
deliveries oh i don't like traffic
no traffic deliveries i'm in
nothing too big as long as i can drive
my tugboat on the highway
how about a duck boat captain that'd be
good for you nah that combines traffic
and you know i i know and plus i'm
dealing with the people i remember i was
super stressed out driving home late at
night we were leaving here
and there was this guy in the east river
on a [ __ ] some sort of ship nothing
not huge to the point where you're like
how do i navigate this but like a you
know a a nice sized vessel i'll call it
a sailboat he had about 13 souls on
board
it was i was just like that's his only
thing that's his only worry at that
moment is just driving that is getting
that boat to where it's got to go
there's no other
we got to see what happens or whatever
this guy's just his sole focus at that
moment
is driving that boat you know that's
what i would love that you know where
i'd get nervous where the bridges
when the bridges go up
they're gonna hit them
i wouldn't like that
yeah they go up so you don't hit them i
know they're scary
okay plus i feel like
that's why you're a land mammal you're
in there eating hot dogs i'm making the
hot dogs you don't think you're eating
hot dogs i'll have one
maybe okay at lunch and i'll sell
chocolate milk too i'll get the best
chocolate mug maybe make my own
because uh hot dog and chocolate milk is
a fantastic combination i think i see a
good bright future really i would also
love to own a cafe like a get it like in
a small town
the coffee shop in a small town
on like main street i just don't want to
get up earl you got to be there at
[ __ ] 5 a.m to open up these
[ __ ] get their coffee i'd open
up around noon
after i had a bacon egg and cheese
couple of heaters
your clothes you're in there eating
breakfast
come back
smell the bacon and the coffee coming
out yeah dirt bag
maybe in another life or maybe when we
we retire maybe we can do that we each
go our own way we open up a hot talk hot
dog cafe on a tugboat what open up a hot
dog cafe and a tugboat i wouldn't mind
that would you come would you if i had
captain a boat would you come out
uh i would have there would have to be
some kind of catastrophic
fall or something what i have to lose my
legs or something what do you mean like
lieutenant dan
otherwise if i if i got if i bought a
boat uh-huh and learned how to i mean i
know how to drive a boat but got my
license yeah would you come out on the
boat with me what am i doing they were
going out for a nice relaxing day oh
yeah of course i'd come out once he
asked me if i come work for you no yeah
you think i want you on my boat that's
what i thought you meant get out of here
no you're not you oh you're not worth
your weight
greenhorn on the uss baldy yeah right
nuts
you'd be eating all the bait i'd buy a
submarine it'll sink you
get caught in a crab pot
uh all right here let's see
uh this is from eric uh
there's a strict 12 o'clock cut-off time
at the grocery store for beer sales of
course i'm there at 11 58 and some lady
is fumbling coupons to pay for 20 in
groceries in order to get beer i had to
pay for her groceries is that garbage or
a pro move pro move one hundred i'm real
good at finagling that yeah oh why can't
come on i would go put it all together i
got it i put it all together i got it
but if there's nobody in because they do
the same thing in new york on saturdays
you can't buy beer after two o'clock
because it's encroaches on the sunday
two two a.m two a.m yeah yeah yeah so i
go in there grab it my friend you can't
have that you can't have the star okay
no problem wait till everybody else
leaves the store if there's somebody
checking out yeah listen can i grab this
[ __ ] there you go yeah here's 20 for
yourself ring it up bring it up in the
morning or whatever yeah you know
whatever you got to do yeah the [ __ ] out
of my face with that yeah it's a [ __ ]
pro move right there
if you can pull it off and it
accomplishes your mission and some
[ __ ] ding dong is [ __ ] everything
up just i got it let's go yeah yeah
that's what almost got me fired from the
grocery store this guy was bitching
about [ __ ] like 38 cents on a can of
tuna or something i was over i just um
well dude talk about in the weeds it was
like [ __ ] the day before thanksgiving
or christmas or something the lines are
like all the way to the back of the
store and you're just like in it like
every register's open you're running out
of money you had the whole [ __ ] nine
yards
and i'll never forget i was in the
express lane
12 items or less okay i'm not there cook
i was the fastest gunslinger in this
that's the major leagues right there
express lane at christmas cooking
i can really [ __ ] future tugboat captain
and this guy was complaining about the
thing and it was like there's one
manager for 15 [ __ ] registers she's
running around like a chicken with her
head cut off there's only one key to
come in and over why is that can i ask
you this is your guy on the inside i'm
on the inside [ __ ] key at the grocery
store because you can't not everybody
can have [ __ ] keys
i mean you're holding everybody up i
know but the thing is so it's like
you're allowed to like back back when i
was banging you were a lot of write-off
you were allowed to take anything off
the ticket off the like off the order
yeah that was under 199 or something 199
or under so you didn't have to get the
otherwise you could just be like oh you
have you know a 58 [ __ ] ham or
something or diapers or formula you just
take it off i would just wouldn't scan
it to begin with if i was committing a
crime but i was not
just saying i just wouldn't scan it and
then be like take it off whatever
um
but if you give every cashier a key then
the key loses its thing then anybody can
just do whatever the [ __ ] they want you
know i gotta be a little more johnny on
the spot i don't disagree with you but
we're so we're [ __ ] that's what i'm
saying this [ __ ] manager's running
around lisa she's running around tight
little body on that one really older
broad too
old shout out looking she could be in
like a [ __ ] uh
you know like a
like a
[ __ ] rat music video or something you
know what i mean okay round and round
she had like the feathered like very bon
jovi-esque probably got your little
roll-up going
fake set of cans on her too running
oh man the manager of a grocery store
with a fake set that's all right pretty
cool
it was all she dating somebody that
worked there uh probably like the head
deli guy no no no no killing it no she
was dating her married to somebody that
was in the same yeah it was uh somebody
it was a frequent i don't know he might
have been like one of the meat purveyors
regional manager or something like that
yeah somebody with a future
and she would like you know
i don't whatever um
she's running around she doesn't know
what's going on we are proper in the
[ __ ] weeds
and i was like hey man he's like yeah
can you come back with me to like check
out the price
he's like
it's labeled at 58 cents but it's
ringing up at once is this an old old
man no this is like you know 40s okay
like you know
and
40s maybe 50 and i'm like take the can
of beans get out of here and like
sometimes you give you a smack you would
send a bag or be like hey can you go
check this go check to make sure you
come back oh yeah it is or whatever but
i mean the bagger they dude they didn't
make it through lunch those guys [ __ ]
either quit or died
they're
on the beach it's like oh my god yeah
that's what i'm saying they're i look
over the kid's head's gone
schwendeman what are you doing
um
try to bring up some mandalores so i'm
like open dog
this is this is pre-self-checkout too
we're [ __ ] proper hemmed up
so i'm like there's no one to go back
and now i'm like i'm like dude it's it's
[ __ ] 38 cents or 40 to whatever i'm
like it was chain it was it was under 50
cents because i remember i took out um
50 cents 50 i took out two quarters in
my pocket and i was like i got it man
because there used to be like a quarter
uh we used to be able to get
uh store brand sodas for a quarter
in the break room not bragging shot
through the root beer that [ __ ] acme
would blow your [ __ ] hair
and two soft pretzels from the deli good
night
i was [ __ ] carbo-loading
i'll be napping on the broccoli if you
need me
oh man i forgot about that goddamn come
back and see me man i get i think i'd
get two root beers
screaming the cola sucked but the
[ __ ] root beer was a heater shitty
root beer is always better i don't know
why yeah for some reason the trashier
the name the lower the the lower the
rent the better it is i'm trying to
think i guess it was sweeter what was
that what was the name what was the acme
brand i want to say it was acme to be
honest with you signature's best or no
america's best was super fresh might
have been signature selectors i know
that's uh i like a signature select uh
whatever it was whatever but so i'm like
i had two quarters oh was it right cola
r-i-t-e no i think that would have been
shoprite probably okay whatever that was
all right
no pun intended diet one of those
diet dude i didn't do diet i didn't do
diet coke until 2022. my aunt had had
the diabetes so she had she had some uh
sugar-free candy and some diet root
beers floating around her house not too
shabby in a pinch my
my pop would do uh
[Music]
caffeine free coke sure gold coat yeah
all right when they would come up they'd
get two or three of them after they i
wasn't about to touch it while he was
there but once he went back down to
shore
hippie was [ __ ] a couple screaming
cold one on them yeah they were all
right man they were okay he would come
up for christmas in january the first
week of january he was gone
you ever do a chocolate saudi
once i don't mix business and pleasure
you know what i mean that's not my cup
of tea
i'm [ __ ] either you guys see these
people at work tomorrow yeah right or
left i'm not a [ __ ] i like a
chocolate soda they were usually sure
i've had a chocolate covered potato chip
not a fan really uh-huh again
what are we doing you know reese's cups
is putting uh potato chips in in the big
i'll try
i'll try i've been looking at that thing
yeah stay away you're already you know
stay away put some money but i got one
of those on layaway at a 7-11 near me
you can have you can yeah once you lose
weight you kept thank you um
but so i offered the guy 50 cents i
already had one
falling out of your pocket
i offered the guy 50 cent he got all
[ __ ] bent out of shape yeah what the
[ __ ] it's not about the money i go well
in this moment it is about the money
about the money man i said if it's not
about the money come back tomorrow and
fight it like this is not the time
important write an email dork
a bagger just shot himself
he's uh yeah and i was just like hey man
we can't fight you know and like i got
written up i'm like hey man you want me
it's a so he was this much of a prick
that he [ __ ] bitched about 38 cents
which maybe [ __ ] was tight which i i
understand i get it but it goes but then
a fir and you're a [ __ ] kid 16. this
wasn't a couple weeks ago
a moonlight
kind of save up money for a boat what do
you want
working two jobs to get my tugboat so
then i couldn't imagine doing that with
a kid
going and [ __ ] well this is the
problem
these people get real [ __ ] lippy to
cashiers
sure
and i'm also an i mean it's a [ __ ]
move that's a [ __ ] move my job is to
[ __ ] go find out what the right price
is if he's saying it's not ringing up
wait hold on who's it
get the [ __ ] out of here you were being
a [ __ ] you're hemmed up you're doing
for the greater good this guy's not the
[ __ ] only guy in acme he's not the
only guy that's got to feed his family
at [ __ ] christmas i understand but i
mean it's also would have taken like
like yeah
it would have taken an extra 90 seconds
or something oh wow i was just being an
[ __ ]
but like that's you know
if dude imagine if you went to some
place and you were like oh
the the coffee running up his two bucks
i thought it was a dollar and he's like
it took a dollar i was probably like i
got it you'd be like you'd want to
[ __ ] torch the place
you would
anybody gives you the slightest attitude
you're all bent out of shape yeah but i
wouldn't say anything if it was if it
was 50 if they rang up it was a hundred
dollars i'd be like whoa hunter i don't
know i'm just saying live in a
hypothetical here you that would bother
you if somebody did that regardless of
his reasoning for doing it maybe he
didn't have the 50 cents maybe whatever
he was like hey man this is the wrong
first little kid with a mustard on his
face and yeah [ __ ] root beer breath
yeah probably that's what i'm saying but
i also wouldn't [ __ ] criticize it if
if it was
that big of a line if it was a regular
saturday and you were running your mouth
yeah would it be sure to the desperate
times call for desperate measures over
here and i'm all about that i understand
no but i'm saying like
he is
if it is marked at a price and then i
it is coming up another right that is
his right to be like hey man that's the
wrong price
i like that you're defending this guy
he had you written up yeah he ratted on
you a grown man went and told on a kid
that still kept my job written up i was
17. there was no consequence to that all
right i was living in my mom's house you
gonna write me up go [ __ ] write me up
every day i don't give a [ __ ] trying to
lose this job anyway i'm trying to go
down the shore the [ __ ] are we talking
about as long as i can see them canes
yeah where's tina
lisa
lindsay i forget her name um
you ever been written up fully
have i i threw a book at him you're
kidding me yeah i got redmond written up
a couple of times
i didn't realize it was a thing at first
time i got rid of it i was like yeah
what are you going to put it on my
perimeter you send me attention what do
i care my boy was like that's how they
make sure that you don't get
unemployment i was like oh [ __ ] get rid
of that oh i didn't even know that yeah
i was in a union though so she could
have written up my [ __ ] rep was there
[ __ ] get buffalo in the case
[ __ ] out of here i was a teamster i
think it was
i think i think those i think the retail
workers and grocery store workers
shows up shuts it down yeah yeah [ __ ]
that now i got written up um
uh
at bear burger
by my gm who i was tight with but i
think just did it to like flex a little
bit i didn't really do anything i expect
that move yeah yeah
keep your fat ass in line yeah keep me
in line because it was if you got three
write-ups then you were fired then you
couldn't collect unemployment yeah
yeah you're also i mean you know good
luck with that by the way
go in there and [ __ ] razzle dazzle
coming in the neck brace the next day
yeah
when i walk in [ __ ] to the hearing
with nine blind kids
see if you're not gonna cut that check
wait why are the kids born
more of a sad story okay
can you believe these kids can't see
um their last wish is for me to get this
money this one's
they're blind they're not dying
i didn't say it was all fleshed out
we're riffing here
uh this one's from cut toby's hair uh
did your dad ever have a wanted osama
bin laden photo printed on a computer
paper taped to the window of his pt
cruiser
that's [ __ ]
old-school [ __ ] yeah no no pt cruiser
thank god but i remember that that phase
did hit the wanted that that headshot of
his sure you weren't finding that in a
[ __ ] yeah that wasn't floating around
in a
frame no that
that was all came across as like you
know almost like good luck terry you
know what i mean like something in the
office it was like never the ink was
never right sure it was like the [ __ ]
jiffy lube printers yeah yeah there was
no laserjet doing those nobody yeah that
was very like
and you had to like rip off the edges to
it yeah no but the pt cruiser phase hit
my my parents friend group
a little hard there was like two or
three couples that got him because
things were pretty good back then i
believe
that was when things were kind of doing
well
where are they i don't know everybody
says that about all the times i think
everything's just the same but i feel
like when like our parents started
buying those things they were doing like
renovations and they were put the kids
were just off at school ponzi schemes
it was all fake money
you thought everything was great until
the economy crashed you [ __ ] idiot
i don't know what i'm talking about when
did that crash hardest my tim dillon
right there crashed in 08 right is that
when it all went downhill yeah right was
about to enter the job market
i got out of college with like 15
million dollars in debt and they were
like hey entry levels 19 000 a year oh
my god great
paying [ __ ] student loans for the
next 78 years
[ __ ] that's how they get you
try to get you
uh this one's from thomas ever taking a
sig break during a cigar
no which
that's what i want to do when i'm
smelling like i smoke cigars with versey
and like midway through because i'll be
drinking too like midway through would
be like oh just i'll be right back when
i go smoke a cig
i want to because it's that like you're
like kind of teasing yourself
i'm having this hail a little bit nah
it's not the same
ain't the same
okay
i don't [ __ ] with the cigars okay
not man enough for them not man enough
nah can't do them
can't don't i like a nice little guy
every now and then but i probably won't
go i probably won't have one because i'm
off to bernie so it's like i don't want
to yeah i think the second you start
it's kind of throwing that it's like
i'll just say
which the rippers have been on my mind
recently heaters
welcome to the club kid
i'll come to the club
all right this one's from bobby bad news
first question for this ten dollar homie
is it garbage to have a mashed potatoes
bar at your wedding had all the fixin's
available cheese bacon chives sour cream
etc etc uh
this has become a trend like the seven
different macaroni and cheeses and stuff
hold on in principle
it's trash
well why i don't tell you why
i mean i can tell you why i think it's
trash
there's no fixings for mashed potatoes
mashed potatoes baked potato is where
you would do all that stuff who's
putting all that [ __ ] on their mashed
potatoes i think that's that's crazy i
think that stuff would come on mashed
potatoes like a tgi fridays or something
you get like the cheese and the chives
no maybe he did mean
maybe he may he meant baked potato all
right i'm okay with that
cheese chili in my head when i read it i
read it as baked potatoes not mashed
potatoes but you read it as baked
potatoes no no no i in my head he wrote
mashed potatoes
i'm saying but my when you were like
it's trashy i didn't think of mashed
potatoes i wouldn't even call it that
trashy with a baked potato but i don't
think it is i mean i mean i also don't
hate the idea
that's kind of very cold stowed creamery
for mashed potatoes
sure can mix them all up
i don't have ever had mashed potatoes
that had a whole bunch of [ __ ] in them
really why would you they're already
perfect
they really are
no well thanks a little bit about the
corn and stuff i might get it all going
what yeah
i mean i don't like make a soup
but i use it as an adhesive to pick
other stuff up you fat little bastard
it's thanksgiving
you gotta trowel out slapping mad
potatoes
yeah no i like uh i'll i'll use it to
acquire other things and what do you eat
on the porch what the [ __ ] is that what
do you mean
i'm not gonna stand here and take this
slander like you don't put multiple
things on a spoon i do or but i don't
mix i don't put things in my mashed
potatoes like i'm not i don't mix it
but if i'm at thanksgiving i'm trying to
get
some of everything on the fork oh of
course you are yeah
what are we talking about oh all right i
apologize to the gentleman from bucks
county well what information were you
running with other than you said you
don't mix the corn he uh he had the same
reaction no i'm saying i said i use it
as a heat i'll i'm about to quit not
working for you psycho that's nuts no
but i i do remember like kids like
their parents making like cheesy mashed
potatoes and they're like what the [ __ ]
is this
get out of here with that did they have
mashed potatoes at your school lunch a
little little
dunk of gravy in the middle i never
[ __ ] with that
stuff i'm a big mashed potato guy mashed
potatoes dude mashed potatoes at lunch
is a wild choice
in the winter when it's cold you're
crazy maybe some fresh oven roasted
turkey that's a wild meal to have at
[ __ ] 10 34 as an eighth as an eighth
grader that's crazy who's eating lunch
attention lunches are early in [ __ ]
school do you start at 7 15. once you
start at like 10 45 yeah maybe for your
classes i think that doesn't make sense
we rolled in at one or two little
there's no way you're having 2 p.m lunch
in in any school that that's impossible
you're lying nope
no you're alive we we all ended the
three we ended it at 2 50. high school
ended at 2 15. yeah we took a late lunch
we'd have an espresso we'd relax a
little bit it's like you went to high
school in madrid you [ __ ] liar
all of the prawns and uh you expect me
to believe that you walked into school
at 7 00 a.m and didn't
in there holy [ __ ] i was starving when i
got there
god damn
i remember sneaking up to the [ __ ]
upstairs cafeteria that had a vending
machine that must have been stocked in
valhalla it was legendary and they had
the tasty cake uh eclair pies you know
the tasty cake pies sure tasty cake is a
local philadelphia uh uh bakery bakery
company fantastic in the eclairs and
they would be perfect
freshens yeah
knock one of those down
hachimachi
no i couldn't make it but we weren't
eating at 10 30. yeah i mean i was at
least graduating i was exaggerating no
lunches started before noon in in every
sort of school you went to
you clearly already stated that you were
lying about the one and two just give me
that lunches started at like 10 45 11.
all right i never had mashed potatoes
uh but we got to wrap it up gang i think
mashed potatoes at a school lunch is
perfectly acceptable
that's what i i'm not saying they're not
ex but
live in the real world how many times
have you gone out to lunch and ordered
mashed potatoes that's a wild choice of
food to eat looking back i've done it
more than you would think to be honest
i'm also not shocked
but the most regular humans aren't
walking around getting mashed potatoes
and gravy with [ __ ] open-faced turkey
sandwiches for lunch ooh i didn't say
open-faced turkey sandwiches but i like
where your head's at yeah gang we
[ __ ] love you to death kippy what do
you got for him anything check out the
live shows guys come see us on the road
those tickets are moving yeah
we love you we'll see you next week
peace